a
era ecuador la tasa de contagios de
hombres desde el 27 de febrero hasta el
20 de abril de 2020 fue de 55 a 44 por
ciento en hombres frente al 44 60 por
ciento en mujeres según un estudio
publicado por esteban ortiz prado médico
especializada en salud global y salud
pública de la universidad de las
américas en quito a cifra oficial reveló
que 46 6% de los contagios corresponden
a mujeres mientras que 50 y 3,4 por
ciento corresponden a los hombres según
el experto de inmunología de la
universidad de las américas
nikolaos kiriakidis existen factores de
conductas como el tabaquismo o el
consumo de alcohol que conlleva a más
fallecimientos en hombres aseguró el
especialista
las enfermedades simultáneas o
comorbilidades carácter crónico como
diabetes hipertensión obesidad son
factores que también constituyen a la
mayor gravedad del cobi 19 en los
hombres el especialista también aseguró
que las diferencias del sistema
inmunológico beneficia a la mujer
según el experto porque posee más altos
niveles de detectores de virus que
generan una respuesta inmunológica con
mayor rapidez y mayores niveles de demás
componentes del sistema inmunológico
y reaccionar de manera más robusta y
eficiente
[Música]
en chile también el género tiene un
impacto sobre nuestra reacción sobre la
cob y según un estudio de la asociación
de la red de investigadoras chilenas y
el observatorio de equidad de género
publicado en julio en la franja de edad
que va de los 18 a los 85 años la tasa
de mortalidad era un 60% mayor en el
caso de los hombres quienes además
tenían más posibilidades de resultar
ingresados en un hospital por sufrir
consecuencias graves de la enfermedad
sin embargo esta tasa cambia bastante a
partir de los 85 años entre los 85 y los
89 son las mujeres las que tienen una
tasa de mortalidad mayor que a partir de
los 90 entre los 90 y los 99 se llega
casi a duplicar por ejemplo en el caso
de la región metropolitana en ese
momento en el que 800 56 mujeres frente
a 486 hombres fallecían por cada 100.000
habitantes el estudio establece que las
brechas de género confirman un efecto
diferenciador de la pandemia en el que
se combinan factores biológicos como la
genética y hormonales junto a otros
sociales como la división social del
trabajo los índices socioeconómicos los
índices de pobreza ruralidad y también
de la concentración de población
indígena
[Música]
mira no es un país muy acostumbrado a
diseccionar en las cifras pero se
conoció en mayo cuando llevaban tres
meses de la pandemia que la diferencia
entre hombres y mujeres fallecidos era
de 2 a 1 en mayoría de hombres como
muchas otras partes del mundo sin
embargo como afectado una pandemia a las
mujeres ha sido muchísimo mayor que a
los hombres en este país por muchísimas
razones en estos siete meses de pandemia
más de tres millones de personas han
perdido el empleo la mayoría de ellas
mujeres que trabajan en esos campos
laborales más afectados como el turismo
los hoteles las agencias de viajes los
restaurantes pero también la violencia
familiar se ha hecho mayor las
autoridades dicen que el número de
llamadas pidiendo auxilio se ha
incrementado en un 30% en estos últimos
meses y es que muchos atribuyen que a
las responsabilidades que ya tenían las
mujeres se les ha aumentado el cuidado
de esos hijos que ya no van al colegio
el cuidado de ese marido que ya no va a
trabajar lo que ha hecho más difícil su
vida
[Música]